the girag an experience that's a guy
thing like guys want to see like yoga
pants on a chick yeah like a girl could
walk down this tree with yoga pants and
a camel toe totally acceptable yes I
walk down the street with fucking ballet
tights on and no shirt Jesus Christ is
Hugh Jackman that's not real yeah no
it's not come on that's not real that
guy's face is Photoshop you're so full
of shit look at the guy on the left tell
me that's not look at the light at all
the lighting is totally bad it's not
real there they have their shadows are
in the wrong direction Hugh Jackman
shadows coming towards us this guy's
shadow is going towards his left
shoulder that's unreal get the fuck out
here how dare you think that dudes HC
achen probably yeah be smart shredded
out bro um we were for whatever reason
Brian was obsessed with the fact that
Hugh Jackman was k he wouldn't stop
talking about it it's fucking hands
remove it he kept puffing on the glass
dick he's like here you Jacqueline's gay
there's multiple pictures of him holding
hands with guys come on saunas multiple
pictures of me with big black dicks in
my mouth but I did hold on a second hey
back that up because one of those look
real it's Craig go piss you weak
bladdered son of a bitch who's the guy
with the beard he's a Wolverine fan he's
telling them how watching that movie
made him cure cancer that's what it is
so Hugh Jackman's guy on the right let
me see is he really holding that guy's
hands out of perspective I don't like a
perspective thing mmm I just who cares
if he's gay but it's a weird thing like
a chick can be gay like a Jodie Foster
and everyone knows she's gay she's out
it's all good and she could play Lee
okay that is super gay yeah but I sexy
beast is that's prolly he looks so this
look so big but you know if a woman like
Jodie Foster be decides to come out and
you know proclaim that she's gay that's
not real either stop it just stop stop
now it's a rule i lost my pants what's
this guy doing sucking my cock I didn't
plan this um tell you funny story and as
some of your listeners know I had the
first jiu-jitsu Academy in the
eastern seaboard in these coasts and
exercise mattresses and at one point we
had to got by the name of Jeff Hamilton
who was a philadelphia eagle football
player this guy was probably about six
foot five to seventy five at the time if
I remember correctly unbelievably strong
in lean in slim he was the darling of
the Super Bowl the year that the the
Eagles went to the Super Bowl in
Jacksonville he was called up he had
actually been released from the team but
they had a couple injuries and they
called him in and went in there caught a
couple touchdown passes wow so he's he
comes to my jujitsu class and it's like
whoa way med jiu-jitsu was designed to
protect us for guys like you man you
know what do you do with a guy i mean
just ungodly strong yeah he came to my
kettlebell class it's the first time i
ever had to break out like a 48 kilogram
kettlebell just to teach this guy swings
was even a telegram was out about a
hundred pounds that's 100 he I mean he
was just like doing front up rises with
you know front front raises with his
shoulders he was just so ridiculously
strong so he gets going with one of my
brown by thurs I'm fella by the name of
Ron haxan who lives in Hawaii teaches
know why now but at that time ronnie was
a brown bout and ryan gets him of course
you know in an arm lock right from the
mount and the guy literally does a
Turkey's get up with Ronnie then they
lift him up how much does ronnie way
prob about a hundred forty eight pounds
at the time under 50 and you know this
guy's like 275 he literally does a
Turkey's getup is putting Ron's head
through the ceiling oh I remember
screaming cuz I you know this guy was
like really an important part of our
team don't hurt don't break Ronnie don't
break Ronnie put him down what if that
it was insane man yeah they're just
insane just how strong some people can
be I mean you mean once you came to
America yeah well and what I was trying
to get at was like what is it what's the
opinion of America when you're living
over in England does it look like when
you see people we're invading
Afghanistan fucking blowing up Iraq and
sending missiles into Pakistan from
robots that fly in the sky or sucking up
all the oil all over the world stuff
didn't bug us at all well you're fucking
awesome neighbor no I didn't know
fucking friend marny's ever what really
fucking pissed us off guy serious
loading today is when you come into our
pubs with your shitty rain jackets you
know hoboken also is this weekend yes
what the fuck matt farah we didn't do
nothing i don't own a single North Face
I know nokia over here with his bullshit
shit yeah so you know that I'm surprised
when you know you get beaten up we're
old inner harbor what I'm in the UK wait
a minute wait a minute wait don't be
surprised we get beaten up I'm always
surprised when i get beaten up ok you're
getting beaten up so often that you're
not surprised I feel like god damn man
you gotta fuck down some go to different
places you're gonna talk to people nicer
just fucking getting beaten up left and
right that's not surprising you're
fucking making some critical errors
basically everywhere you go I'm my
fucking constantly shocked and I'm
beaten up every time it's ever happened
a billing what the fuck did I do this
led to this let's break this all down
and never repeat this problem again he's
like wow they were wearing the wrong
jacket so we had a cone of them I picked
him up for the Queen ok you can see my
got the wrong colors on North Face
Inquisition and you was born on the
wrong patch at dead we signed the
Patagonia charter in 2014 knuckle
sandwich coming your way mate Oh for
vendetta we have all-weather gear ok you
know what we do what are you afraid of a
little mate now we try to get your neck
wet
you